Now, back in the early 90's, specialty hardware was used to get smooth graphics
on early machines. Things like the NES, Genesis, and Gameboy had custom hardware
that was built into the form factor that was allowed you to draw tons and tons
of tiles very quickly on modern screens. Now desktop computers at the time didn't
have that much power, in fact, they didn't have any of that specialty hardware
at all. Modern desktops around that time running at 33 hertz were considered top
of the line. Now, one day a young John Carmack made a demo called Dangerous Dave
in copyright infringement, which actually showed off a Super Mario Brothers 3
level running at full 30 frames a second, on desktop hardware. He showed that
demo to a young John Romero and that very day ID Software was born. The same
studio that went on to actually create the first person shooter genre with
titles such as Wolfenstein, Doom and Quake.
Now, the trick that Carmack realized to get the same performance from the
specialty hardware on the desktop, was actually an optimization. See, these
early machines weren't too good at actually copying pixels over here to over
here in memory. It was actually a pretty difficult concept, especially with the
bitmap colors and everything. But what they were good at was actually just
copying rows of memory from different registers. So what Carmack realized was
that he could use the previous frame and somehow just use meme copies to sort
of shift it, so that it looks like the scene is actually scrolling. They need to
be able to only have to update the small portion of the screen that changed as
your character was moving. Thus was born the concept of "Dirty Rect". Now, this
is the same concept that's been used today in tons and tons of games. See,
that's the trick with game industry techniques like this: they never really
die, they just kind of get rebranded as technology evolves over time.